Sup y’all?
Grab yo’ tissues and pop some Zoloft cuz
today we weepin’ like a bunch of bitches
with Where the Red Fern Grows by Wilson Rawls.
Billy Coleman rollin home from work one day
when he see a dog fight goin down in the streets:
a whole gang of em jumpin a Redbone hound.
Afta’ shakin’ dem haters off, Billy take
dat pooch back to the crib to give it some
love and care.
Dat puppy chill-sesh throw us in to a FLASHBACK,
playa!
Back when Billy was a lil ‘un, he was hittin’
his parents up fo’ a dog.
Pops like “Aight, son.
We’ll get you a lil pup from the neighbor’s
place.”
But Billy like “Bitch please, I want two
redbone hounds so I can hunt coons.”
That’s RA-coons!!
And daddy all like: “Da hell you think this
is boy?
We ain’t got da ends fo’ dat.”
So Billy hustle fo’ TWO DAMN YEARS til he
save up enough cheddar to buy a couple dogs,
and his gramps help him order em.
When the dogs come in, Billy hear he gonna
have to wait a week before he gets em.
But Billy ain’t gonna just sit on his ass
and wait, so he hikes 20 miles ONE WAY to
scoop em up.
Billy end up gettin’ one boy puppy and one
girl puppy, and since it’s gettin late,
decide to set up shop in a cave and hold it
down til morning.
When a mountain lion roll up tryna mad dog
em, da pups don’t take NO shit and start
hollerin’ right back “WOOF WOOF MUTHAFUCKA”.
Billy start screamin his ass off and throwin
rocks til eventually dat puss turns his ass
around and book it.
Next day, Billy leave da cave and peep two
names written on a tree and decide THAT’S
gonna be the dem pooches names: Old Dan and
Lil’ Ann.
Back at home, Billy’s gramps help a brutha
catch a coon, and then use da fur to teach
Ol’ Dan and Lil’ Anne how to HUNT like
BIG DAWGS.
Billy recognize dat Old Dan got da muscle,
but it’s Lil’ Anne who got da brains.
One da first day of hunting season, Old Dan
and Lil’ Anne chase a coon up da phattest
tree in town.
Billy promised his pups dat once they cornered
one of dem suckas, he’d do the rest.
So B-money bust his ass for DAYS tryna’
cut dat tree down.
Jus’ when he bout to say “fuck it,”
he get down on his knees and start prayin’
fo mo’ strength..
Then what do ya know?
WHOOOOOSH- a big ass wind blows the tree down
and the pups GIT dat coon.
As da months go on, word on the street is
dat Billy and his pups are da best hunters
in da hood.
Knowin he got da game sowed up, Grandpa make
a bet with da local Pritchard boys sayin dat
Old Dan and Lil Ann so trill that they can
even catch the mysterious “ghost coon.”
And jus’ like the G-UNIT they be, Billy
and the dogs pretty much CATCH it, but Billy
don’t wanna kill da poor thang- he just
feelin’ sorry for it.
When Rubin Prichard gettin’ all up in Billy’s
grill fo’ bitchin’ out, Lil Anne and Old
Dan start whoopin on Rubin’s pooch.
Rubin grabs an axe to fight off the dogs,
but he chokes and accidentally ices himself.
Later, gramps enters Billy and the pooches
in to a hunting competition.
Not only do Lil’ Anne win “sexiest bitch
in town”, but after nights of roughin it
through a redonkulous blizzard, the pups bring
home the GOLD CUP.
Now Billy and his fam are 3 Benjamins richer
too.
Later, Billy on da hunt when Ol’ Dan and
Lil’ Anne corner a damn mountain lion in
a tree.
When da Mountain Lion start scrappin’ with
da pups, Billy grab an axe ready to bang out.
But it’s the dogs who gotta save Billy’s
weak ass.
They eventually kill the Mountain Lion, but
Old Dan gets fucked up in da fight, and dies.
Lil Anne can’t go on without her puppy-bro,
so she stops eating and dies too.
Man.
Fuck this book.
I’m done.
(Sparky walks off screen) Billy just cain’t
figger out why his pups had to die.
And you know what?
Me neither.
Bullshit, man.
Ain’t all bad though, with dat swole stack
o’ prize money, Billy’s family can finally
get outta da boonies and move to da city.
On the day of the move, Billy visits the dogs
graves, where dere be some red fern growin.
Brutha get all riled up and bout to chop it
down, but then he remember dat according to
Native American legend, only angels can plant
dat shit and dat it last forever.
So he decide to leave it, knowin’ dat he
ain’t never gonna forget da way those dogs
affected him fo’ the better.
Mah boy Edgar Allen Poe once preached dat
there ain’t nuthin’ mo depressing than
losin’ a lover.
Guess dat fool never lost a dog.
...Yeah I cried.
SO WHAT??
Like Billy himself say on page 16, da love
between a man and his pooch ain’t like da
feeling you get when mackin’ on a hunny
tryna get some action.
Nuh-uh.
This is some of da realest love in the game.
Them dogs keep it so real that they willing
to lay it ALL on the line to get their boy
Billy’s back- and it ain’t just cuz they
loyal.
Check what Mr. Kyle say on p. 184
And it ain’t jus’ Ol’ Dan and Lil’
Anne gooin hard fo’ Billy.
Matta’ fact, Billy show dat kinda love ain’t
a one way street: he ALSO grindin hard in
the name of love.
When da pups run a coon up dat big ass tree,
Billy gonna do what he promised- cut dat tree
even if it take him a damn year of sweatin’
his balls off to do it.
And you best BELIEVE he follow through, cuz
Billy is one of the most DETERMINED cats in
da hood.
Whether it be hustlin to stack enough cheddar
to buy the dogs, or teachin’ em to swim-
Billy neva’ trippin in the face of a gnarly
challenge.
He just beast through it like a G.
But sometimes, determination ain’t cuttin’
it fo’ Billy.
He need somethin’ mo.
A buncha times throughout this book, Billy
start prayin’ fo strength, and after he
do, he able to keep it clutch and get shit
DONE.
And just as God pitied Billy and decided to
help a brutha out when he in need, Billy always
showin’ love to otha’s when they in bunk-ass
situations- like when he told he gotta ghost
da ghost coon, he pities da poor thang and
tells Pritchard to step.
When da big man upstairs shows you love, ain’t
no doubt it’s legit to pay it forward.
But when you lose somebody or something that
mean mo’ than life itself, how you gonna
keep da faith?
Maybe yo prayers don’t always get answered
da way you want em to, but that don’t mean
da big G-man ain’t lookin’ out for you
in other ways.
Peep this convo between Billy and his dad-
All deez fresh themes- love, sacrifice, pity,
and God, come together in da image Red Fern
that growin on dem dogs’ graves.
Word is dat only angels can plant summodat
red stuff and it last fo’eva- jus’ like
the memory of Lil Anne and Ol’ Dan inside
Billy’s dome.
And like he say at the beginning of the book,
after all these years, Billy feel like a piece
of him still buried under dat fern.
Yuh, this is a kids book, but it force us
to stare down the barrel of one of da realest
questions they is: is there anything you love
enough
to give yo’ life for?
Thanks for checkin me out, son.
Catch y’all lata.
Peace.